you brought a picture Oh what have you
show during that one of your children
drew and I think you should examine one
more child your only child okay that I
know where is it I don't know I think we
have we have it my plane what's going on
you okay so this is a picture my wife
and I just celebrated 12 years of
marriage in May yeah she drew a picture
of her and I kissing it's very sweet in
this week and then there's a what she
called a construction dude looking at us
he trying what any and it says true love
and we had we were doing some work on
our house so there are some construction
workers around and I the first I saw had
two thoughts when I saw this I was like
first of all what a sweet picture I mean
to get a picture from your kid is great
and I thought what is sensitive
construction worker guy he's working on
the house he's busy he sees you two
embracing hello and he cries like like
Bryce Dallas Howard I was weeping away
they're amazing that the best yeah I
know so that was a joy